bonjour mon nom est katherine et je suis
atteinte de phd le phd ou paige 10 ou
filet philosophie et doctor comme on
l'appelle parfois c'est quelque chose
qui affecte de plus en plus de monde
peut-être que vous en avez dans votre
entourage peut-être même que vous en
souffrez vous même
j'utilise le mot souffrir parce que
voyez vous c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui peut amener son lot de
souffrances j'en sais quelque chose ça
fait onze ans que j'ai officiellement
diagnostic mais si je remonte à plus
loin se fait même qu'un aidant à locker
que ça s'est installée alors si vous
voulez bien dans les prochaines minutes
je vais vous proposer une sorte de guide
à l'usagé de l'entourage des phd
dans un premier temps on va voir
ensemble comment dealé avec ce qu on
fait ça s'attrape et comment être à
l'affût des premiers signes des
symptômes précurseurs
ensuite on va voir les symptômes humaine
parce qu'il ya quand même des signes
assez évident de ça et enfin on verra
comment peut- être soulagé un peu le
piège parce que ça se guérit pas
vraiment mais on peut quand même amené
une certaine amélioration à l'état des
personnes affectées alors allongé avec
les modes de propagation
d'abord c'est important de savoir que le
pied et je dis c'est pas une tare
génétique c'est pas non plus héréditaire
même si des fois pour diverses raisons
ça peut fatalement se retrouver dans la
même famille il n'y a pas vraiment
encore d'incidence qui ont été
démontrées non on fait le principal mode
de contagion c'est vraiment par contact
direct avec d'autres personnes infectées
le lieu principal de sa le campus
universitaire l'université foyers de
propagation depuis 1500 ans
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est
à l'université ça veut pas dire
nécessairement qu'on va attraper le ph d
un c'est pas automatique comme ça on
peut traverser très bien un certain
nombre de temps
des contacts prolongés avec des gens
atteints de phd semble développer
soi-même
je vous dirais que l''indice auquel il
faut le plus faire attention c'est la
maîtrise
si quelqu'un dans votre entourage fait
une maîtrise soyez vraiment vraiment
vraiment attentif c'est le symptôme
numéro un qui pourrait malheureusement
déboucher sur autre chose
prenez moi par exemple à 24 ans à un
moment donné bon je me suis remise d'une
maîtrise lost est formidable mon
entourage avait enfin repris espoir de
me voir sortir commencé à voir du monde
et même travailler mais je me suis pas
et vous voyez vous parce que bon j'ai
continué quand même fréquenté ce lieu de
contacts et de de fréquenter des gens
atteints et puis bon après quelques
temps il a fallu que je me rende à
l'évidence puisque je la vois mon
entourage j'avais contracté le ph d bon
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça ben
oui une fois qu'on est infecté il ya
déjà que s'en remettre spontanément ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle en à peu près
je vous dirais de 60 à 70% des gens
atteints de phd vont connaître une
rémission spontanée dans les premiers
mois
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle ça veut
dire qu'il ya quand même de l'espoir
c'est pour les 30 à 40 % autre que ça va
se compliquer un vont vraiment connaître
toutes les phases excuses et ça me rend
toujours très émotif parce que c'est
quand même encore douloureux
il ya des gens qui s'en remettent pas du
tout ils deviennent même des agents
actifs de propagation de phd leur nom
scientifique professeur méfiez-vous
alors quels sont les principaux
symptômes un camp comment on reconnaît
un phd quand on en a en face de soi s'il
ne vous en informe pas lui même alors le
premier symptôme qui va s'installer très
très rapidement dans les toutes
premières phases de l'affection c'est la
recherche aux la recherche aux basses et
une espèce de compulsion a accumulé une
somme incroyable de documentation
d'information de données de savoir sur
des choses qui m'ont jugé à peu près
inutiles à la vie de tous les jours bon
mais ça le psg ne s'en rend pas compte
ça fait aussi partie du symptôme alors
il va foncer tout simplement dans cette
accumulation la constante il va finir
par s'isoler pour toujours accumuler
davantage parce que ça c'est intéressant
ça s'apparente un peu à une nanny ça se
nourrit de soi même plus le ph des
recherches plus il veut rechercher et à
l'impression d'en avoir toujours besoin
davantage donc comme un aspect end de
dépendance qui va s'installer et
nécessairement d'isolement aussi si la
recherche aux n'est pas prises à temps
on va voir assez rapidement par être le
deuxième symptôme la méthodologie tu la
méthodologie c'est que face à toute
cette accumulation la de connaissances
et de données
le phd va ressentir un impérieux besoin
de toute analyse et classe quelle
classifiés faire des fiches et souvent
de d'administrer les méthodes qui sont
franchement ils ôtent eric est connue
d'à peu près lui même mais peut-être
quelques autres personnes atteints de la
même variété phd que lui alors là ça va
encore les débouchés sur beaucoup
beaucoup de solitude parce que pour
mener à bien toutes ces cogitations aux
intenses
le ph des votes isolés s'isoler et ça
aussi ça fait partie des on pourrait
dire c'est pas un symptôme en soi mais
c'est quand même un élément un indice
qui va s'installer en périphérie de la
méthodologie est naturellement ça va
constituer une sorte de frein à la
communication saine parce que voyez-vous
le phd va être convaincu que tout ce
qu'il a accumulés
dans sa recherche osé dans ces phases
aiguës de méthodologie bon c'est
passionnant alors il va en parler mais
c'est difficile pour les autres de
comprendre ce dont il parle d'ailleurs
ça m'amène au troisième symptôme qui est
selon moi le pire
ok les rues disent écoutez ça l'érudit
sme ça se caractérise par une enflure
verbal une enflure verbale qui va être à
la fois à l'oral et à l'écrit une
enflure aussi qui va se manifester de
façon quantitative quantitatif parce que
le ph d ou celui qui était en phase
aiguë des rues dix neuf à se mettre à
parler à parler puis à parler et a parlé
de son sujet étant en travaux rentrer
dans des phases de mutisme aussi alors
là il va s'enfermer avec beaucoup de
procrastination va se remettre en
question jusqu'à la prochaine fois où il
voir débouler avec ces choses donc
quantitatif n'ont plus vraiment
manifeste mais aussi qualitative et là
je me dois de vous avertir la prochaine
image pourrait choquer
ok il ya des personnes qui sont
sensibles je vous invite à détourner les
yeux et par l'espèce je ne prononcerai
pas directement les mots que vous allez
voir parce que il faut le dire les rues
10 mhz ça ressemble un peu à un syndrome
commanderie ah oui le syndrome de gilles
de la tourette est ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose
ça c'est quand quelqu'un ne peut pas
s'empêcher de dire des gros mots des
jurons c'est complètement involontaire
et ça se fait dans des lieux des
circonstances franchement inapproprié
alors on ici on à faire un petit peu à
ça avec les rugissements phase aiguë le
le ph des vols proférer des gros mots
mais de nature assez particulière alors
vous êtes prêts
bon je sais que c'est violent
je suis désolé c'est pour que vous
compreniez à quel point on est rendus
loin dans la maladie quand le phd ce
même utilisé ces mots là de façon aussi
courantes que s'il parlait de brosses à
dents aux bicyclettes en soit ça devient
des mots d'usagé ordinaire alors là vous
êtes vraiment face de quelqu'un qui est
une atteinte neurologique pousse les il
faut faire vraiment vraiment très
attention pour le récupérer
cet usage de violence verbale va faire
en sorte que celle entourage on va
observer un phénomène curieux parce que
voyez-vous avec les rues 10 mhz
c'est le phd qui développe peut-être
cette enflure verbales mais c'est son
entourage qui va développer l'irritation
et ça va mener encore là une aggravation
de cet isolement et de l'incompréhension
va voir vraiment un mur entre le phd et
son entourage même je voudrais les gens
les plus proches de lui ou d'elle et il
faut faire attention parce que
précisément parce que c'est une
irritation
vous savez on a tendance quand ils
irritent à sion à appliquer du froid
assez spontané pour calmer une
inflammation on dit il faut mettre une
source de froid dans le cas d'un ph d si
le contraire si vous êtes tenté de
mettre la relation sur la glace c'est
vrai que ça peut amener un soulagement
pour l'entourage
mais c'est la pire chose à faire pour le
phd lui même
je vous explique pourquoi les méthodes
de soulagement bon je vous ai dit ce
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il faut pas faire
je peux maintenant vous dire qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire parce que faut
comprendre que le ph d quand il est dans
sa phase là vraiment c'est comme un
tunnel et dans sa recherche osé dans sa
méthodologie et vidé des crises des rues
10 d'épouvantables c'est dur à vivre
et pourquoi le laisser tout seul dans
cette espèce de brouillard là qui va
s'installer
c'est très très important que
l'entourage soit là pour lui ou pour
elle ce important que le phd se donne
une chance oui il faut commander en bon
québécois se botter les fesses et
essayer de sortir un petit peu c'est
possible pas avec d'autres ph.d mais
vous comme entourage son entourage vous
pouvez et devez quand même le ph d
inviter la sortie à prendre un café à
prendre un verre aller au cinéma c'est
important de l'entourer d'amour de
l'entourer tout court il ya la
zoothérapie aussi qui peut donner
d'excellents résultats
parce que en obligeant le phd à son
descendre un peu de son enflure
cérébrale pour s'occuper d'un petit être
vivant mais ça va l'aider à garder ses
deux pieds bien au sol à ce grade et le
commander en anglais et il faudrait
aussi que certains animaux constitue une
barrière physique franchement
appréciable entre le phd et ses travaux
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de
tout ça ce que j'aimerais vous dire
c'est que en quelque part phd ou non
ph.d je pense qu'on a tous quelque chose
à mener à la société ce qui va faire la
différence entre un phd heureux ou un
phd malheureux un phd qui contribuent ou
un phd qui dépérit c'est vraiment
l'entourage parce que le ph d laissé à
lui même il va tout temps s'enfoncer
davantage à ses très lourd tout seul la
recherche aux les rues disent ça pèse
sur ses épaules il peut finir tout
simplement par être écrasé par tous
appuyé connaître une sorte d'isolement a
gravi un ph très heureux par contre qui
est bien entouré qui est bien récupéré
par son entourage va être capable de
faire circuler les idées qu'il a
accumulés ça va faire en sorte que les
connaissances si durement acquises vont
servir à quelque chose finalement
ils vont contribuer à la société parce
que c'est le cas chez adp hd qui ont eu
de grandes réalisations que ça soit en
astrophysique en linguistique en chimie
même en musée il y en a dans tous les
domaines à des péages des attentions
donc ces gens là peuvent être très con
contributif peuvent vraiment être
contributifs à la société mais pour ça
s'apprend l'entourage et moi je suis
persuadé que derrière chaque phd qui ont
réussi à s'épanouir que réal qui réussit
à sortir comme ça il ya eu au moins une
personne à un moment donné à quelque
part dans son processus qui le prix
comme cela par les épaules leur garde et
vous vraiment dans les yeux qui lui a
dit écoute c'est important ce que tu
fais je crois en toi
pich tm donc à toutes ces personnes là
en mon nom personnel mais aussi au nom
de tous les péages des belges veux vous
dire merci et à tous ceux qui auront à
croiser un phd
un jour je vous souhaite d'emprunter
cette direction là avec lui pour le
meilleur de la société merci